[Music]
an environmental destruction is a form
of warfare as ukrainians by this point
know all too well
and so does Russia and that's why they
are deliberately targeting
the environment and people's livelihoods
and homes
and therefore also destroying lives
because this is after all a matter of
people it is about people it is about
ukrainians suffering but from this war
it is also of everyone else suffering
from the consequences for example the
millions of people depended on food
grown in Ukraine just as one example I
think that no one of us remains
unbothered while seeing the horrific
developments that are taking place now
in Ukraine and the crimes committed by
Russia
um and I hope that we that we can
gather the assessments from from local
ngos from the scientific Community from
authorities and so on to to create
assessments of the environmental
environmental damages that are happening
and and so that we can create
accountability so that Russia is held
accountable for his actions and its
crimes and so that the affected people
can have a possibility to recover and
that's so you that you Ukraine can
reconstruct
uh in a sustainable way atrocities they
leave us
at loss for words
um
I think it's hard to to react to to
these things that are actually happening
especially for people who aren't
experiencing it firsthand
um so I think we need to make more room
for people who are affected by these
catastrophes to tell their stories and
to share information of what's happening
on the ground